Darkling beetles are known for their armor-like
exo-skeletons
and their ability to thrive in dry
places. They also know a thing or two
about fitness.
The flex their abdomens like belly dancers
this pushes oxygen through their tracheal tubes
But what about the pupae?
For a long time scientists assumed that only adult bugs pumped their abs to breathe.
Now, using high-powered x-ray imaging,
researchers have found that teenagers do it too. However,
the teens pump their abs to breathe only forty percent of the time.
The rest at the time researchers believe the pumping
might help blood circulate through the
fragile bodies
as they prepare to enter adulthood.